don't have my game face on today I might
lose I wasn't a successful that I want
to speak or very long time but the older
I get the more I appreciate that process
your life is yours to live and when you
let the voices of others drown out your
inner voice well you let them start the
talking is they start dictating how you
move need motivation bacha top ten with
believe nation
he's trey songz and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
be true to yourself anybody that you
know puts their passionate devotion yes
a love day time yes you know dedication
into uh you know you're gonna get upset
about that from time to time you're
gonna get and not only upset you don't
have every emotion about what it is that
you do when you really love it yeah
you're gonna you gonna cry sometimes
about it you don't you're gonna get
angry sometimes you can be really happy
about it but it's gonna be times that
you're very upset whether it be in the
way somebody perceives your music
whether be oh mike getting cut off yeah
it'd be you playing your music for an
executive and they saying I don't think
that's it
you know what I mean is is so many
things as far as artists concerned so
when we speak about like working with
people were like what's left is so much
more left cuz I'm still finding myself
you know I mean so as I make music and
continue to make music I I just I just
want to be true to me as a person
rule number two work hard I don't have
my game face on as the day I might lose
you know that's the part of your focus
that's the part of knowing what you
signed up for I know what I want from
this and I know what it has what it
takes to get there hard work ain't never
scared me I know what is I know what it
felt like to not be the highest to not
be as brother pen to not have tops to
top ten single after top ten single or
number one single after no missing
so those moments are fresh in my mind
and I work hard to make sure that I stay
here my personal life actually takes
back seat at times to this and I
understand nothing my family understands
that and I work hard to get all that it
is that I want rule number three
appreciate the process I always tell
people to do the biggest biggest
benefits in my career was probably in
the beginning the thing I hated most
like I was how long it took me to get to
where I feel was why I was getting my
chest do yeah you know my first I became
of course the crib is going crazy just
gotta make it gotta go like Wonder Woman
everything and our nucleus on the East
Coast week but I wasn't as successful as
I want to speak with very long time but
the older I get the more I appreciate
that process that learning curse the
ability to grow gradually so I had to
learn everything in front of everybody
I gotta get catapulted immediately into
success that gave me appreciation for
the journey to get to success that gave
me appreciation that made me work hard
like that's why I work as hard as I do
now today cuz I feel like if got to make
it would win number one Billboard chart
top with success my first thing will
ever own I don't think I had this thing
is behind rule number four compete with
yourself I don't write down goals and go
get them you know I know a lot of people
do that but I just kind of try to outdo
myself I'll do my last I'll do and
although this is a competition and in
every sport and I look at this industry
as a sport because it's its numbers and
its money and its achievements in is
Championships and etc etc you know I'm
only really in competition with myself
you know although it is you know a fun
competition I look over and see what
your homie doing to see you know I mean
for me it's all about bettering me
better than the music I make better in
my fan experience bettering my business
bettering myself as a man and the truth
is there's a lot I want to accomplish in
the music industry that's a there's a
lot of one accomplished accomplished as
a businessman you know I haven't done a
lot of those things yet although I have
done a lot
feel like I'm just getting my feet wet
and the ceiling is very hot for me also
if you want to see more excellent to the
black community check out my 254 series
it's free the link is in the description
below as I make music and continue to
make music I I just I just want to be
true to me as a person rule number five
don't listen to the little man
you're fillers get hurt in situations
where people let you down
yeah or people you know take your name
to you know do whatever for have success
what I think we as a people get to in
golfing is what everybody else has to
say about it like your life is yours to
live and when you let the voices of
others drown out your inner voice or you
let them start the talking and they
start dictating how you move you got to
stand out you got a you got to be strong
within yourself rule number six believe
in yourself
I love to do music so I always rap in
our always and you know the funny thing
about was when I was rapping this thing
is like it was a summer out of this
world what he's gonna sing and rap but
he's R&B singer like in a beauty I love
about music nowadays is that you have
artists that almost everybody do both
right you know what I mean so I think
that's a great part of the evolution of
music is uh artists being creative and
believing in themselves no matter what
box that people try to put them in
because no matter what you're trying to
do it's your life other people don't try
to put you in this box definitely but
you got to push through it
rule number seven strive to be better
don't matter how great I am how many
records I sell them at how many hits I
have I'm only a man I'm not better than
the next minute now I was at a elevated
level more in demand and you know less
of my time is mom when I work hard when
I worked very hard but I could work
harder it's the way I look at it like
and I'm doing very good but I could do
better I'm very successful but I won't
live
that moment rule number eight make your
presence felt it was a point I was
putting on a new song every week you
know it was Trey Songz music Monday I
put out a new song every Monday for like
two and a half months before my mixtape
came out which was anticipation which
got 50,000 downloads the first night you
know
ready came out Ray's had six or seven
singles I think that has a lot to do it
come on - with jay-z who's an
international superstar definitely
brings a lot of tension in my name
perform with Stevie Wonder on the bTW on
his uh you know I kissed Toni Braxton on
stage you know like so it was a lot of
steps towards where I am now and I think
that it's just beginning even still you
know that's why I this run is so gentle
Pat my schedule that's why I'm in a
different country every day cuz I need
to make my presence felt
and even when I come back next time I'll
work even harder to make my presence
felt because I still am working here
this time like I'm gonna do right my
manager told me we're gonna come on we
gonna act like it's 2005 and what that
means is act like I just gotta make it
you know so I don't know how Phil is
doing a superstar here yet I'm working
my way there rule number nine do what
makes you happy they're not in it just
for the money
you know cars cars clothes I suppose you
know that that's and that's the tricky
thing about this song you know is that
when I say I suppose it's kind of like
thinking in hindsight is that really was
successive I was not that's that's what
success is perceived being well it's
what that it is through TV to movies to
videos etc but success is really what
makes you happy
yah-ha making music makes me happy and
real number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is have fun hey
can I get the ladies to make some noise
no you gotta just up clouded go
that would be straight back to the crib
[Music]
Finnick is something that you won't
forget no I just wanna see you
[Music]
now I've got two very special bonus
clips on how to do it yourself and stay
focused that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go
question number one what will you do to
make your presence felt this week number
two where do you need to work harder and
number three what can you do to believe
in yourself you and then it's gonna be
critics as you mentioned earlier critics
don't determine you you live your life
for you you do as you do for you because
the moment you start to live your life
for others you lose yourself within that
focus on what it is that you want to
have okay I read that you said something
about you've been getting a lot of
scripts but you've been putting your
acting career kind of on hold to get
this album finished and out this album
and my musical career altogether I want
to make sure that it's at a certain
level where as though when I when I take
acting seriously and I want to step into
that arena I could play ball with the
best of them you know I don't want to
try to juggle too many things at one
time because when I'm when I'm focus on
my music I give it my all and if acting
is something I want to take seriously I
want to be able to do the same with that
if you like this video check out the top
10 I did on Drake the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there while you're on the journey you
have to disconnect from the end goal I
think every time I say I'm about to do
something people are waiting for me to
fumble I never want to be always right